fides are the comet and clearly a few
very exhausted and overtired but
nevertheless very happily directors and
operation managers they're in the main
control room just now ladies and
gentlemen there are some very happy
people standing here all eager to say
their bit first of all I would like to
ask Joe jack donaghy Issa
director-general on stage Monsieur so
difficult so Sofia Joe Pierre so Pierre
rakia theater did Boise oh okay you have
all you ever all heard that fillet as
landed and to take what professor surely
enough was telling us this is a big step
for human civilization and because this
is a science scientist knowledge and
that this is certainly terrestrial
intelligence that makes the difference I
would like at this stage to to repeat
what I say after each success the
biggest problem of success in that it
looks easy and especially for us who are
not doing anything so and when you know
the some of expertise the some of
dedication to some of team working
between 20 nationalities of member
states of Europe plus cooperation with
international partners when you know
that you know that this type of success
is not coming from the sky it comes from
hard work and for expertise because the
only way to reconcile risk and expand
success is the expertise this is the
reason why today we have demonstrated
that the European expertise be that
either between industry in national
space agencies in research centers
everywhere this is the best expertise of
the world because we are the first to
have done that and that will stay
forever thank you very much